today on the matt walsh show a
restaurant owner in los angeles has her
business shut down
even as a hollywood studio is setting up
catering tents
literally right next door meanwhile
actors on snl
and talking heads on cnn lecture
lockdown protesters for being selfish
quote
babies but we'll talk about who the real
selfish babies are here
and five headlines including the chicago
teachers union speaking of selfish
babies claiming that it's
racist and sexist to open schools again
and a doctrine organ has his license
revoked for criticizing masks plus
your daily cancellation and much more
coming up today on the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
before we get going today you know
especially as we get into the holidays
we're all doing uh probably uh some
shopping and you're out
you're out spending a lot of money at a
lot of different companies and the fact
is a lot of those companies
don't support you or your values and
that's a problem we run into
as conservatives in the culture and
that's why when we find a company that
really supports us and shares the same
values it's important for us to support
them
because it's really a win-win situation
and that's where charity mobile
comes in that's the pro-life phone
company i'm always telling you guys
about there's a reason for it because
five percent of your monthly plan price
goes to the pro-life pro family charity
of your choice
and on top of the great charity that
they're doing it's also a wonderful
service
new activations and eligible accounts
get a free cell phone with free
activation and free shipping
there's no contract there's no
termination fees there's no risk with a
30-day guarantee which means you know
they're not trying to suck you into
something you can't get out of it
and you won't want to get out because
it's just a great service live customer
service based right in the usa if you
ever have a problem
and need to talk to somebody and also
you can block
you know picture messages cellular data
text messages you can control
your child's phone you can protect your
kid that way which is also really
important
free usage alerts to keep track of how
much data you're using
and all kinds of other stuff if there's
a free app to monitor your usage
pay your bill much more which which just
makes everything a lot easier as well
so you can help build a culture of life
in america while supporting a pro-life
company at the same time
like i said we're talking the ultimate
win-win situation
what you got to do is call charity
mobile at 1-877-474-3662
or chat with them online at
charitymobile.com
so a couple of days ago a restaurant
owner in los angeles named angela
marsden recorded a video with her honest
and raw
emotional understandably emotional
reaction to her city shutdown order
she like so many restaurant owners in
the area and elsewhere in the country
had the rug pulled out from under them
when you know she spent lots of time and
money setting up an outdoor dining area
only to be told that outdoor dining
would be banned there's of course
no coherent reason to ban outdoor dining
well there is no good and coherent
reason
the actual reason is that politicians
want to flex their muscles grab more
power
tighten their control over the
population that's plenty coherent
i mean it makes sense but it isn't very
good at least it's not morally ethically
or constitutionally good
in any case angela marsden's video has
gone viral for good reason
and if you haven't heard or seen it
we'll play a little bit of it here uh
here it is
i'm losing everything everything i own
is being taken away from me
and they set up a movie company right
next
to my outdoor patio which is right over
here
and people wonder why i'm protesting
and why i have had enough
they have not given us money and they
have shut us down we cannot survive my
staff cannot survive
look at this tell me
that this is dangerous but right
next to me as a slap in my face
that's safe this is safe
50 feet away this is dangerous
mayor garcetti and gavin newsom is
responsible
for every single person that doesn't
have unemployment
that does not have a job and all the
businesses that are going under
and we need your help we need somebody
to do something about this
what you're hearing there by the way
that is uh righteous indignation that is
real
righteous indignation okay that's that's
that's what righteous indignation sounds
like doesn't sound like you know
a college student claiming that they're
being persecuted because they have to
pay back their loans now this is someone
who's losing everything while hollywood
studios are setting up their tents now
if you're wondering a report in the
independent says that
the setup was for caterers for the film
crew of the nbc show good
girls and this is really neither here
nor there i suppose but wikipedia tells
me that the series quote
follows three suburban michigan mothers
two of whom are sisters
who are having a hard time trying to
make ends meet they're tired of having
everything taken away from them so they
decide to pull off an unlikely heist by
robbing a supermarket
only to discover that they're in for
more than they bargained i just wanted
to read that to you because the fact
that exceptions are being made for this
vapid ridiculous television show
only highlights the arbitrary cruelty of
all this
but obviously if those tents were for
the crew of a good show what few exist
it still wouldn't be any less outrageous
either way
hollywood productions are now considered
essential
essential to whom is the question they
may indeed be essential to the people
working on them but in that sense all
jobs are essential and that's been my
point all along all jobs are essential
because
they all have at least one person who
depends on them for survival
but are these productions essential in
any other sench sense
are they essential in a deeper sense
than say a restaurant or a bar is
essential no in fact i'd say that
your local restaurant where the
community comes to gather together and
share a meal is far more important to
that community than
good girls on nbc good girls on nbc
could disappear
from the face of the earth and nobody
except the people working on it would
even notice or care i didn't even know
the show existed until right now
even the fans of the show would
immediately replace it with some other
show
not missing a beat or stopping to mourn
but when a favorite local business goes
under
as many of them are right now you feel
that loss if you're in the community
it's a sad day even 20 years later you
may be driving by the place
where the business used to be and you'll
turn to the person in the car with you
and you'll say i remember i remember
there used to be a bar there called
so-and-so and man i used to love that
place et cetera et cetera
20 years from now nobody's going to be
talking about good girls on nbc or
remembering it fondly
this all simply highlights the injustice
that we've been witnessing
and it's one of the great injustices
ever perpetrated by the american
government on its citizens
that is not hyperbole the government is
arbitrarily wiping out thousands of
businesses
all at once while allowing the more
powerful companies and
industries to keep running and even to
more than that
increase their profits and all the while
the people having their lives destroyed
have to endure the lectures and sneering
from the people whose lives have only
improved if anything during the
lockdowns for example
pete davidson a man who is about as
witty and charismatic as a dead tortoise
but who still pulls a paycheck as a
professional comedian somehow
was on snl this weekend to mock the
lockdown protesters as nothing but a
bunch
of babies listen i take it that you
found these protests frustrating
yeah man they're making us look like
babies you know you know it's bad when
even people in boston are like ah
drink it home you quiz
and do you think that people should stay
at home until the pandemic gets better
yeah everyone wants to go have fun but
there's plenty of stuff you could do at
home
like use your official pete davidson
vibrator
yeah great great jokes there um that's
professional that's professional comedy
by the way
you know why people don't want to eat
drink outside because uh it's
it's a high of 40 degrees today in new
york that's why
that's why restaurants are are going to
lose their business if they have to send
their people outside people aren't going
to sit and eat and drink at 40 degree
temperatures
but anyway he says baby yeah baby says
says the 27 year old man who still looks
acts and sounds like a seventh grader in
after school detention
a man who more importantly has a job is
making money
has not been financially devastated by
the lockdowns
it's funny how the people who support
the lockdowns and sneer at those who
protest
and resist the lockdowns are almost
always also people who still have jobs
you notice this in the media too all the
time here's a segment that aired on cnn
a couple days ago
listen to this cnn talking head speaking
from his studio at his job
as he explains why those who are asked
to give up their jobs
shouldn't complain that much listen
what's happening in los angeles i just
want to make clear
it's a huge sacrifice he's asking for
but it's not
everything retail stores are still open
there's a lot of offices still open
movie television production which drives
the economy out there
it's still happening he's just asking
people to make sensible
decisions and when you look around the
world you see it works
you see what's happened in these
european countries where they've
instituted measures
like this for short periods of time and
it breaks the rise it just does israel's
done it like three times
you know they keep having to do it but
the country is willing
to do it by and large and when they do
it it
it just stops that incredibly fast
rising cases and hospitalizations
it works i mean it works so much they've
done it three times that's how much it
works
they work so much they just keep doing
it
yes it's uh it well it's a big sacrifice
he says but but uh but come on
you know we can do it and besides
walmart's still open that should be
solace to you if you lost your job it's
not the end of the world what's the
problem
it's not everything he says you're not
asked being asked to give up everything
of course he's being asked to give up
nothing
so the guy who's giving up nothing wants
you to know that however however much
you're giving up is not really
that much in the grand scheme of things
this is why it pains me so much that the
people who push for lockdowns
also get to pretend that they're the
compassionate and selfless
ones the truth is whether lockdown
shutdowns and masking
are the right or wrong approach and i
think they're wrong obviously but
right or wrong if you're pushing for
them
you are almost certainly pushing for
them because you're scared
and you want to feel safe you know you
want other people to do something to
submit to something to give up something
to give up everything
potentially for your sake to protect you
never is this more clear than when
four-year-olds are required to wear
masks to walk through a store or get on
an airplane
that isn't to protect them they're not
at any significant risk from covid
they also aren't at any significant risk
to spread covet yet we want them muzzled
we the adults so that we feel safer
around them
and that guy on cnn or pete davidson
they want the bars to
stay shut and business has to close down
so that they can be safe
they are asking other people to make a
sacrifice
for them call that whatever you want to
call it but don't call it compassion
don't call it courage don't call it
selflessness
it's exactly the opposite it is
cowardice
and fear and that's what we should call
it
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
by the way um not to brag but uh on
a more uh on a on a lighter note uh i
did finish my christmas shopping already
uh pretty pretty incredible i've got
i've got a big extended family
plus four kids and i managed to get it
all done
three weeks before christmas and when i
say
i i mean my wife uh my wife got it all
done
i think or she will but my i got her her
gift
that's still my only job around the
holidays and my only point here is that
uh
this is all i'm saying because the
holidays can be stressful but what i
would recommend if you're a man
and you're stressed around the holidays
get married so if you're right now and
you're three weeks from christmas and
you're a single guy you're stressed
about the holidays
just run out and get married real quick
and that'll take care of it
it is it is really stress-free to be a
man during the holidays
um i like i can't recommend it enough i
love it and then the great thing is
here's what makes it fun is that
um when everyone's opening their gifts
on christmas
i get to find out what i gave them
you know so it's always a nice surprise
i also find out what i bought for myself
and it just it makes the whole
experience great and uh it's it's really
it's really wonderful cannot recommend
marriage enough
for many reasons that's just one that's
not the only reason but that's one of
them
all right what i don't recommend though
is public schools and uh
this is just one of the reasons the
chicago teachers union deleted this
tweet
after backlash uh maybe you could tell
why there was backlash
it says the push to reopen schools
is rooted in sexism racism and misogyny
no explanation provided for that claim
there never is is
i mean we're at a point now where they
just they don't even try to connect the
dots
whatever i don't like is just racist
sexist it's all of them it's not even
it used to be i feel like they would at
least pick
when i say they those on the left they
would at least pick one of those
and they would try at least tangentially
to connect
they would say oh this is racist because
and it would always be a weak reason but
now it's just they just throw them all
at you no it's racist sexist homophobic
transphobic
sure why is it that but it just is
just is admittedly it does remind me
of the arguments i used to make when
schools opened up again after a
snowstorm
this is back in the days before the
internet so kids they don't know about
this but you would uh you know you
gather around the
the radio it snowed last night you wake
up you see the snow
you gather around the radio in the
mornings early in the morning like 6 a.m
you're waiting for the news break
just waiting to see your here your
school district
and then they say you know your school
district opening on time
absolutely crushing but i used to shout
this is racism
racism and sexism i won't stand for it
that argument didn't really work um but
then again it was okay
you know for me to hate school as any
self-respecting student does
but for the teachers union to hate
school and to have no interest in
opening them
ever again it seems that's a much bigger
problem
though it's not surprising and this is
why the teachers union is
a blight on the earth a parasite
especially on the on education
and they should all be forcibly
abolished in my view
there is there there is no nobody
benefits from the teachers union
education doesn't benefit the teachers
might benefit some of them
a lot a lot of teachers hate them too
but
the education system is supposed to be
forget about who benefits
the education system is supposed to
exist for the kids that it educates
that it ostensibly is educating the
teachers union
does nothing for the kids doesn't even
pretend to care about the kids
and that's why teachers unions shouldn't
exist in my view
this from the daily wire says the oregon
medical board has indefinitely revoked a
doctor's license after finding that he
and his staff refused to wear face
coverings during the ongoing cove 19
pandemic and encouraged patients
visiting his clinic to remove theirs
concluding he is a serious danger to
public health
the panel voted on thursday to issue an
emergency suspension determining that dr
stephen uh la tulip or la tulipe
la tulipe let's just call la tulip
engaged in unprofessional conduct or
dishonorable conduct
nbc news reports that the punishment
comes weeks after
the doctor spoke at a stop the steel
rally outside the state capitol in salem
on november 7th
a video uploaded to the multnomah county
republicans youtube account
shows the doctor speaking over a
microphone down playing corona
coronavirus has a common cold
and condemning mitigation policies
ordered by government officials
as nbc news reports according to the
emergency suspension
the doctor in july allegedly told a
patient who asked for guidance on when
to get tested for the carnavirus
that asymptomatic people should not be
tested and that wearing a mask does not
prevent transmission
but tulip directed the patient not to
self-isolate
because being around other people would
provide immunity from covenant 19
according to the state's
state board's documents and then then he
had other sins as well apparently
personally i don't see a lot wrong with
what he said there
um and you know it's interesting because
they say
well all the doctors agree that you're
that you should wear a mask
well i guess it's easy to make all the
doctors agree if the ones that don't
agree
aren't doctors anymore so they say all
doctors agree and then you say
oh this doctor over here doesn't agree
oh him yeah well he's that we'll take
his license he's not a doctor anymore he
doesn't count
my main question though we talk about
revoking licenses
from doctors um i'm i'm a fan of of
of that i think we should be doing that
but not to not not for this
how about revoking licenses from doctors
who
i don't know put healthy kids on hormone
pills you know put a 10 year old on a
puberty blocker maybe that
maybe revoke the license of a doctor who
puts children on psychotropic drugs
because they're having
trouble paying attention in school
and as a side note you know you have to
wonder how many more kids
are being put on this is my guess my my
bets my prediction for the future is
that we're gonna we're gonna find out
that there was a mysterious rise in adhd
uh during the coronavirus maybe adhd is
a is a side effect a symptom of
coronavirus because i
i can i would bet you right now we're
going to get a report there was a huge
rise in adhd
a lot more kids on the medicine why
because somehow they're having trouble
sitting in their computers and staring
at a computer all day
as a form of education so maybe revoke
the licenses from doctors who do that
that would be my that would be my
suggestion number three
uh 60 minutes about 30 years behind the
times apparently ran a segment
this weekend talking about some of the
issues with title ix and
here it is listen to this minnesota
insists that financial pressure isn't
the only reason sports are being dropped
it also cites title ix the federal law
that requires schools to match the
gender makeup of their student bodies
in their sports teams so if 54 percent
of students are women
54 percent of athletes should be too
to get to that balance schools often
choose to cut men's sports rather than
create
new ones for women title ix is often the
scapegoat
when universities cut teams again it's
to protect
the core business which is football but
you can
kind of use this gender justice shield
to kind of throw men's non-revenue
sports
under the bus football is often what
gets universities in trouble with title
ix in the first place minnesota has 115
men on his football roster
which means it needs 115 female athletes
just to balance that single sport
yeah like i said about 30 years behind
the times but it's glad they're finally
catching on um of course this is a this
is a total
travesty i mean it's completely
ridiculous you have 150 men on a sport
means you have 150 women
why why why who says who
well i know who says it but why what's
the reason
yep i'll tell you the real reason why
there aren't as many women playing
sports just because and not as many
people interested in women
not as many women want to play sports a
lot more men want to play sports
also uh men are better at playing sports
most sports anyway and so it's more fun
to watch them
why do more people watch men's
basketball over women's basketball
because men are better at it
and so it's just a lot more fun to watch
it's a lot more fun to watch basketball
where people can touch the rim
that's the reality yeah it might hurt
your feelings it might not i don't care
it's just it's just it's just a simple
reality
this idea that everything has to be
equal you know i raise my kids i mean
this is something
in every parent you go through this with
my with my kids
um especially the twins and all kids do
this
they're constantly insisting that
everything has to be equal oh he
you you gave he he has a 16 cheez-its in
his bowl that you gave him
and i only have 13. i need three more
cheez-its
well with that i'm impressed because
that's good math and then i might reward
you for doing the math
but uh in principle the message from
parents is not everything's going to be
equal all the time
you got to get over you got to grow up
that's that's not the way
life works sometimes someone gets a
little more jesus than you do
that's life move on so that's the
message that
anyway that competent parents or people
who at least are trying to be competent
parents
that's the message we give our kids then
they go out into society
and they're told oh no everything has to
be exactly the equal you got 150
men playing a sport you gotta have 150
women
equal this idea of equality
um is one of the worst things
that's happened to western civilization
i'd put it that way
i'll tell you equality exists really in
two realms okay
equality exists as a as a sort of
mathematical concept
you know two plus two equals four the
same as
so we could talk about equality when
we're talking about mathematical
uh w when we're in the realm of math
and then we can also talk about equality
when we're talking about the inherent
dignity and worth of human beings and
that's and that's what's meant
in our founding documents when the
fountain when our founding fathers
talked about equality
that's what they meant that all people
have the same inherent
worth but that's it as far as equality
among people
that's as far as it goes you have the
same inherent worth as anybody else
there's no one out there who's more of a
person than you
that that's what is meant by it so a
really good example of what happens when
people don't have equality
you have unborn babies who are killed a
million a year 60 million
babies just slaughtered and thrown into
the into into the uh
dumpster outback the medical waste
stumps are or sold for parts by planned
parenthood
that's what happens when we're not
recognizing the inherent worth of a
human being and we're saying that oh
well
they're not like as people-y as we are
we're we're a little bit more
person than them so when people don't
have that kind of equality that's very
bad and horrible things happen all
throughout history
but once we've established that that's
it
that's as far as equality goes men and
women
have the same uh inherent worth and
dignity great
that's that's it with equality we could
put equality on the shelf now
once we've established that with men and
women we can put equality on the shelf
we've got that covered
there is no more equality men and women
are not equal in any other sense except
for that
and any attempt to make them equal in
any sense except that
really basic and really spiritual sense
will
will will lead to absurdities at best
because the reality is whether you know
man woman whatever you sitting there
watching this
me sitting right here you know as for me
every single every person in this
building right now
they are either smarter than me or
dumber than me
they're stronger they're weaker like
it's
we are not equal in any way for better
or worse
from where i'm sitting
it's just the way it goes you got to get
used to it or apparently you don't have
to get used to it that's the problem
you know this is the this message that
we give kids all the time we've got
society working against us
because we're always telling kids well
you know you get into the real world and
you just got it you got to deal with
these things
but then the real world comes along and
says i don't know they don't have to
deal with it
we're going to keep the delusion going
we want your kids to remain
kids forever not in a good way by the
way of like protecting their innocence
no no because
we're we're going to make sure they see
pornography at the age of eight
but uh so in that sense we're gonna take
their innocence away from them but
in sense in the sense of their emotional
maturity
well you know that we want them to be
childlike forever
all right uh where are we number four
okay here are some guys on tick tock
uh they call themselves the good liars i
don't know who they are or what they are
but um
they went to a trump event literally
begging people to wear masks
speaking of having no emotional maturity
um as in on one knee begging
listen you guys got masks
no no why not
because i don't need it why do you need
it i would
yeah you should wear one because there's
a pen there's a global pandemic going on
yeah well you got yours i got mine on
yeah i'm trying to be safe
okay but you could infect somebody else
and and they could get sick
would you please will you please excuse
me will you please wear a mask no
please nope for the sake of other people
please wear one please i'm begging you
please
yeah on his knee begging i think he
needs to get on his knee to his doctor
and beg for some testosterone
supplements
uh i think that's more what this what
this guy needs
but yeah if you're really worried about
a virus you're super worried about it
what are you gonna do apparently you're
gonna go to a uh to a to a rally with
thousands of people
and record a tick tock video yeah that's
what you do if you're really worried
about the virus right
you use it as an opportunity to get uh
shares or whatever is it do they have
shares on tick tock i don't know what do
they do
um all right five finally the the
governor of new jersey phil murphy
had a message for representative matt
gates after seeing images of the
congressman
at an event in new jersey without a mask
on um
the the governor was uh was very upset
about it and this is what he had to say
that guy in the middle the tall handsome
fella in the gray suit
that is representative matt putz sorry
matt gates
uh and based on his past performances
it is obvious being a knucklehead is not
beyond the pale
for him he was actually sarah palin's
backup act for this event now if you go
to the next
kind of a scene that's matt again
earlier this year
kind of a scene out of dr strangelove
what a fool he and they should be
ashamed of themselves he is not welcome
i hope you're watching matt
you are not welcome in new jersey and
frankly i don't ever want you back in
this state
not welcome in new jersey banned from
new jersey
you know that's like if you're if you're
walking on the sidewalk
and a hobo comes out from under his tent
under the highway overpass and says
you're not welcome in my tent
you hear me you're banned from the tent
it's it's it's supposed to be a threat
but um it doesn't really work that way i
would love to be banned from new jersey
every time i have to drive through new
jersey now that i live in tennessee
hopefully i'm
i'm i'm further away that's one of the
great things about farther away from new
jersey it's one of one of the best
things about tennessee
tennessee's got a lot going for it one
of the best things is it's farther away
from from
new jersey but i used to have to drive
through it all the time it's just an
absolute dump
it really is no offense if you live
there but it is a dump
and it smells the whole way through
my god i would love it if i were if i
told you
that that's one of the one of the great
honors i think that could be bestowed
upon a man
is to be told you're not welcome in new
jersey
other than that a really lovely state
though with a lot of great people
before we get to the daily cancellation
you know uh a lot of people
everyone everyone's busy we're all
busier than we should be and uh i know
for me especially having just moved and
if you've moved you know you know what
that's like it just takes
it takes a long time to settle back into
your routine and what i've found is that
i'm usually a big reader
but i found that i don't have the same
time to read that i used to which is why
i love
thinker.org you know what thinker.org
does is they summarize the key ideas
from new and noteworthy nonfiction
giving you access to an entire library
of great books in bite-sized form
uh and what this means is that you know
this there's just even if you even get
all the time in the world you could have
every day you could be you could be a
multi-millionaire retired at the age of
35
living on a beach you're still not gonna
have time to read
and get all the insights from all these
books it's just there's not enough hours
in the day
so even then even if you're the
millionaire on the beach i would still
say get thinker.org
or if you're just a normal person then
uh then even more
so i think we're the ones who need it
most of all uh hundreds of titles in a
matter of minutes from old classics like
dale carnegie's how to win friends and
influence people to recent bestsellers
like jordan peterson's 12 rules for life
i know a lot of people
have used thinkor.org for that
thinker.org offers a large variety of
titles across
many categories they've got current
affairs relationships
business education history
maybe if there's a subject you're not
very strong in and you have trouble
consuming an entire book then go there
or if it's a subject you just love then
that's even more reason
to check out those books if you want to
challenge your preconceptions expand
your horizons become a better thinker go
to thinker.org that's t-h-i-n-k-r.org to
start a free trial
and download the app today let them know
you heard about them on the matt wall
show that's thinker.org
also um we've been telling you about
daily wire membership and if you uh
if you are not a daily wire member yet
then you want to take advantage
and become a daily wire member
especially because you see we got these
brand new
tumblers new and improved these things i
mean i thought before was the most
beautiful thing my eyes had ever
seen um i mean except for my kids and my
wife but
yeah close second was the tumbler but
then they
they revamped it and honestly it might
be number one the tumbler might be
number one now
might be the greatest thing
the world has ever known i don't know
but you can get a tumbler if you become
a daily wire member uh along with a lot
of other things as well because
as we get into the new year and even
before that we're adding a whole bunch
of content the michael
knoll show is now five days a week um
we're adding the entire prageru
catalog to dailywire.com by the end of
the year right now you already can find
uh they got their five minute videos up
on the website candace owen's show from
prageru is there
and uh but pretty soon the entire
catalog will be there speaking of
candace owens she's joining the daily
wire
and she'll be here in nashville with a
live show pretty soon so you want to
become a daily wire member before that
happens so
go to dailywire.com subscribe
we're loud we're opinionated and uh
we're having a good time
and a lot of people had a good time with
those uh i mentioned
on friday those sweatshirts insert woke
slogan here sweatshirts
those are gone those went those those
were were scooped up in like a day
i like to think because i'm the one to
mention them i'll give myself all the
credit for that
but you know what has not been all
scooped up yet are the daily wire
christmas tree ornaments
somehow these things are still available
um it's not because nobody wants them it
might be sort of because of that but
it's
but really it's just there are so many
of them we wanted to make sure that
everyone has a chance
to buy one of these adorable christmas
uh
ornaments all the daily wire guys were
all adorable christmas elves as you know
you know fulfilling a lifelong dream of
my own so please buy these things so i
don't have to talk about them anymore
text christmas
to eight three four zero zero to get
your tree decorated if you if you want
me to stop talking about them
as much as i want to stop talking about
them then buy them damn it eight three
four zero zero text christmas
now now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
well today we're canceling aside from
new jersey uh one of the great villain
groups
in modern society in my opinion and that
would be people who take pictures of
strangers
in public to shame them this has become
i'm sure you've noticed an epidemic
every day i go on twitter or facebook
and
there's some post featuring you know a
photograph of some
unsuspecting stranger doing something
actually or supposedly rude
captured and posted for public viewing
by some sniveling tattletail
the epidemic has grown in severity over
the past few months with the advent of
the mask wars
now if you see someone out at the
grocery store without a mask on
you can hide behind the doritos end cap
snap a photo
i'm motioning like an old-fashioned
photo that you would have like an
old-fashioned
uh you know camera you could post it to
twitter with a with a caption like no
mask get kroger unacceptable
maybe tag the kroger account try to get
the management of your local branch in
trouble while you're at it why not
you're on a roll
you were supposed to just be running to
the store for coffee filters and laundry
detergent
now you've decided to throw a little
public humiliation of your fellow man
into the cart
kind of an impulse buy you might say but
really nowhere is this behavior more
common
than at airports if you've ever done
anything
even slightly uncouth at an airport you
can bet
that there was a snitch in the terminal
or on the plane who had the incident
saved to their camera roll and posted to
twitter
at lightning speed it's amazing that
everyone carries these high-powered
cameras around in their pockets
and still nobody's captured a good image
of a yeti or a ufo
yet everyone who has taken their shoes
off on a plane at any point in the past
seven years
has been photographed in high definition
and i'm not defending people who take
their shoes off in planes i'm as
disgusted by the sight of unwelcome feet
as the next guy
but i'm even more disgusted by passive
aggressive dorks and voyeuristic weirdos
who sit meekly and quietly next to
someone while secretly documenting their
every action
and complaining about them to their gang
of fellow dorks and weirdos on social
media
which brings us to the latest example
this is a guy named michael pollock
uh the tweet has since been deleted but
it racked up like 15 000 likes before it
was taken down
went viral um it's a picture of a young
woman sitting next to him on his flight
and the caption reads flew on southwest
today
woman across the aisle coughing her head
off no mask no seat belt and using her
phone on takeoff
she's also barefoot in wearing pajamas
though he doesn't mention that in the
caption
that part was mentioned though by many
of the thousands of commenters who
jumped in to
join the shaming commiserating with poor
michael
sharing their own stories of people who
had similarly offended them on flights
and elsewhere in life
there were at first anyway very few
people asking the obvious question which
is
why were you sitting right next to a
woman and taking her picture while her
back was turned you creep
well we know why he thought it'd be an
opportunity to grab some sweet likes and
shares
the food that sustains us all in modern
society
and that of course is what is driving
this epidemic of people taking pictures
or filming strangers to shame them
if you're thinking about doing this when
you're out in public if you find
yourself tempted
if you see someone doing something rude
or annoying
and you begin thinking to yourself i bet
i could get 10 000 retweets out of this
just imagine how awkward it would be if
the subject of your clandestine photo
shoot
were to see the post that you put up
about them
while you're still sitting next to them
imagine that they happen to stumble
across your tweet or facebook post or
whatever it is
notice themselves and then turn you and
say hey man did you uh
did you take a picture of me and post it
online
uh yeah i did i did
why did you do that well because i'm an
awkward pitiful nerd i guess
that's why here's my suggestion if you
see someone doing something in public
that you don't like
there are two very good ways of dealing
with it as far as i can tell all right
two options option one ignore it
carry on with your life if the behavior
doesn't really affect you in any way
this may be an option worth exploring
option two
confront the person directly speak to
them human to human assert yourself like
a grown-up use your words
like i tell my kids i have nothing but
respect for people
who do this even if it's even if it's
for a relatively petty reason
if you're petty and confrontational i
got no problem with you
i think it's great i mean i don't like
it when i you know
people get onto airplanes dress like
they're 14 year olds at a
slumber party pajamas bare feet the
whole deal
i was flying next to a man a few months
ago had himself swaddled in a blanket
was sucking on a pacifier that's how bad
it's gotten
how infantile i'm exaggerating only
slightly
the point is if you have the gumption to
lean over to someone and say to their
face
hey buddy can you put your shoes on no
offense but your feet are repulsive
also try getting fully dressed before
leaving the house next time you're
embarrassing yourself
okay anyway have a nice flight if you've
got the wherewithal to say that to
somebody's face i've got
nothing but respect for you i think this
world could use a lot more
direct and honest confrontation not
that's being filmed for cameras but just
person-to-person hiding off in a corner
though and secretly taking pictures is
not direct it's not honest
it's even more childish and emasculated
than wearing pajamas in public
so the public shamers and secret picture
takers are canceled
this particular guy on the plane is
cancer
i have no problem with people being
jerks to each other just to be clear
all i'm saying is do it in person
face to face like a decent human being
and that's going to do it for us today
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening
have a great day godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20. if you
prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there